my ex-boyfriend nick i really do have  his name tattooed back there  do you know how hard it is to get laid  with another man's name on your back  not hard yeah  [Applause]  i was dating a guy for a while he looked  at me and he said it's just that my  therapist told me that i could tell you  that i was more attracted to you when  you were exercising and eating better  and i thought is your therapist  your friend sean i picked up a bunch of  condoms  because i'm the breadwinner of most of  my relationships  it always cracks me up when the dude  chimes in or like she trapped me with a  baby  you have the missing ingredient  and we love to bake you know what what  got me going crazy it's more of a man's  game  than happy ending have any women here  been offered a happy ending  just an angry silence  you